dans le Coran il y a tout et son
contraire d'ailleurs le Coran admet
lui-même ses contradictions dans le
Coran il y a le verset de l'épée mais il
y a aussi il n'y annule contrainte en
religion comment vous vous concilier les
deux en fait c'est impossible à une page
en vous dis il y a pas de contrainte en
religion et on vous dit même dans un
autre verset si Dieu avez voulu que tout
le monde croit tout le monde aurait cru
qui es-tu toi pour contraindre les gens
à croire ça aussi c'est la Parole de
Dieu c'est dans le corps donc vous avez
deux Corans il y a un Coran Pacifique
celui de la Mecque et puis un Coran et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais c'est les
hommes qui ont fait ça comment on fait
pour résoudre ces contradictions là et
les musulmans ils peuvent se référer à
une partie comme à une autre 150 ans
plus tard on est chez les Abbassides
donc dans la construction d'un empire et
là on se dit bah comment on fait pour
résoudre tout ça on réunit des juristes
et puis on décide de l'abrogation de la
partie Pacifique par la partie
belliqueuse parce qu'on est en train de
construire un empire et qu'on a besoin
d'un texte Bell